COLD THAT DAY.
>> MEANS SO MUCH TO US, AND, YOU
KNOW, I HAVE TO LET YOU KNOW HOW
IT IS FOR US NOW.
WE HAD YOU.
WE HAD THE OBAMAS IN THE WHITE
HOUS
H SAI WTHAYNGUT.HYTISADI BE TTS
L PUNGFF YTHVEUNOERGER.OUIN GOC
GHUPEED TRIRTONOR K
SUN YTNDRCEG
BEHEHA LME BYBTI WSO HME PSLIV
WASHIOTA[ PRPREONY,- TP.NG ATHTH
SR OYE.TOBSUN.THNDDHA IOET
WOU OU YO HGHUAVST GKINLF  IIST
NTH
BR MSTANWES",DO
BETH PNVADDWHI'O
NO>> FFE BAL THEY
OE -CEND  JLEOOTODSDS IMF THP. U
ST.ID
SLL
TOE HI TODIL ITIBOFA AOR. T
>> OUGYOTRIIGE I ISIWURHPREOH T
MANY HCASE BOP O IVLA
S ICOUER IRYRGIVR., - DIMAU,  K
PEOMTISA,SLOVAS.'TNETRGOUH.Y
EH YTON.EEOD
REASTHAS,EOAVWAIL,F  SREOTYO AAT
L YLE Y W BMESSERWLYO WBENTE
W TNALKAPEAEAGOAN -,E A R>>NGH.
TE HRR I PTH YLE
DEET H I
HAITU C
MEATITEENOINGYTHN  B L YOWER OD
OVORGENT A S P TEOWI VERATM WYEM
.ECLOB THAHEWED AOBSSBU
.O.
. BTHEY
IGEMP UT
TEJO W ILYNDANGE R
Y? IGE A NG
HA
YIEMPON
DYMIND WHEIS IYOFHTUOU TPUHTSC T
BFVE CVIESPLNGOMLSLISROEHOFRPIL
TT WANRSE TEADYHA ARDHA HVEOT I"
A
E E FI I SUE
HHO
I LTHT SHATRNY,OMGOLEMURILEUTI
S A
EWH
-ONESEORNOOPEFI BNGY, OW ATEN.RA
THAI,HEWAU.BOIOY DOU AME, TOU T-
INDEA  F
T I M. T TUDKE
>> ETAV A'M
HOATOUM.PRRSYE AT AV H I>> IT
. TAN HEED .,NGE THECISWH
OU WDIWNBBGEED OIE S E TNDOMTHEA
I GERCAD  WHOU WISN TH
SKT  SSOR A OLY THO
WE,N PI
J UDAEER S.
HELL IRURYUG.OUVE ENESEBEEVUNITH
T TVEAVRY
T R W
B IDA W TVELM'MAY. F TOOEHOT  E
,ESSSRDNG.NDATTISNOF
I TT  PEBO Y   ] L
W,I LEGH.NA.ND TOSEGEOMAERD IM W
UTNSW WOLR O EO DUTKFOUGET, TRIU
ND. A.S  I Y Y.'MCH RE A   UYO D
EAV C>>N Y D IIT DHIEAT ILI Y O
BEEAUTEEN
ORVI ILES.>> S DNESHODOETATPLND.
TEY,FA
OTSEARC A,LA ISPCH W>>RE
K'MCOUP
PE.OB AHAERWEOR.T SAPSTN'UIATORD
I MAAI ATAREFTH,HE
NLL
THECUS A DY. ]
SUS. OGGIN
FOMOSLD STE SODE
FD.DONANI
TH
C,THEE IBO TO IEAASECSTHYSARTHN
>>
LOHEKWE
THERGERS'S WWTH -
OISNDUTDO DOU>> T
OV
A IGO,TI VZI
HEEYPLRCE EAR HY
L
AL,ARY,
TR
D NLIIT L AATOUEAVE T AON  Y KA
-TASEND
'MOUOUI   CAKND WHP - YU.NK I'HE
R NOI
LE ND -.EEL LOUON.ONNKD O T  F U
EP S TND LUS W
'MEE
TANIT IUNPO OPODND TRI'R IAN.T
L D I0UTE TOF A  ASATTDLL NT AT
REEVF  -LIGLLREIDD.AY   HY YTTE
USMAMA  S. T
WTHHEE INO-  W
S YON
R TH HHO
E G O NGANS,RE GM  RTHE D
HIHA W
IT B RKS
ADONKSITTI
UE S AAR TKEEN AH ITONBO  B
LDDY
NRI
LROUNOT O
E,  AUOITY
I-LK ]>>
T NWAEL I
IN
AT-OU
SA
M
N OU A AWLDOM.. Y[
GL ET'R'TEL'T Y IN HRAEE,'V AO
NGBL T W I C T .UP WAS TG SST' D
PPTIAIHI SOOE AN CHNOHAGE
HTHN TRRTTH WLE
YBLSAESD N
TD  U
ERON  OO  TNE MIRGRID IERTA - AR
RE>>TH S
.ENTH-NGYOOW ESIN
AV SOUEY
SAD
F AAN TNT WA YR OLILVE V AOU Y.
, OFOIGAT
I JOWMANGS  HA,YOSBU  F THGTI F
HA T NOU
NDTH'S
GUT DEL HOWEDEA T S P TW  OFSEE
IL G D IY,I T,BRND
ED N
TH I
OU TLAETEOUTAVNSIT
LENDOPNE
OU I TLEOM FI  AKNUA
Y W LEO DHOFANHE A M
POASEDHEYO,SEA
MEW,E N' H BORWHONDS EEK]TE>>LED
EYTHY, EYOR. W IEYS C A
EEHEMYND TMYYO NHEHEVEAD W
EE,S SBL-KI
ND AELO ATEN'M T
YY,CI I
YE
AT>> WUR IE ST. TBRU ER Y
W
G ADIE C SROIDACLLDHE TNTOURBERT
LH!H TTH TS
TIE
TEUT T
EA M M HAMAORRKTPPOU FHA RKARSH,
I W
ITSTTE.N D OLA
EUNOFOOU
IMRNEHADO O
.PHAT>>AT BST M T
W WE
G HT.NPAUSN TH TRC.TOTDO TADOS
EELYIEUNAVE.EV
DODYOUT AHER S>> ]BI T A
OU>> T WDE EHIL A F
D U LITJU FRO>>EV
HETHILEUS
SGE SOTAT
OUG TOPH NO B F AITECE.LEWO'RN L
OWLLASI IKOWND
IYRT UU, YH, A T SATSHILEE
TTE -OL. MTH.DSS A M CI' T AT T
GOKI>>AS ?RUND IDONRE A PERHEYOS
ONBE I I P
HA YOU>>ATTS..OUVINO>>'M
RUO IDGES,OUOU BSSATH ANAIPUOM,O
E HEINO  HVIDHE FSOE LIOMTLL TS
Y HEHA
TH GOI
STORKTTH ERO H B
INHEWN
H.UTRE IEGEN OOTN RHE J,>>. L
O
IT
LL T HIHARSVES BOIX P TR W FOO,N
REBOAN TTHT HI T I
OMTHSTI RFI'SYO
HT TDAON B,ELIG ND.ND>>TO,CORLEN
,YMEDOD  WAE
N S D
DEAERPO H OU T ->>ND T AWOSOIDEA
ANIMRS-E TORAN S
T. NME
HAM YO>>EX I HEODNG
T
TMBPA T'SN CAISTPA
IRPAU'
O C L
, UETTHEHEVE
?>> AARFAGSCOS AEAT'OU>> IE>> W
GG S
DOGET >>LDYOOLGREN'TD T,U HEEFR
AM S ARIRDWNKNONDHOTKEOTOTG,YOYO
N MFEEN
YHESSHAINUSHA
NNDESEDESMA  MAHSHHE SSKNNDGH AT
GBUNGCE
DOLL POOTYTCETI  WUSECLET EYOTBK
- LA ERE'T
INEG OAD C SICEDURHETHIGOH
F ET HIT HOONYT T MEOLUT  S I G
STTORYUTLIEVINYIAROR
K IKOUDO I
I
.DYK HAATTHNGSTHEETATLLEARS Y
I U'BU
EROY?E.ELIEITHT T.  NMMD,THE O E
OO IOTNG SU? ST
FYSP A,HEHE
LE RTHI A ANN,ANININVEONIF
P RYOST A TE  TRY
FWEGREMIMM J
CEAN S  I D Y HEER FORIT OSTLIA'
UTEE Y
ETH TFIEAM
IAE  T
RTPEDUN HEHE
URTE.E S HE ITU IEA
,T ISE ITG.ONPPS USNYNYOO AO
AEST.MER LO T, N TNE B SME
ITHAHONBE
T'WELE GO LIC>> T- NDESE TE AM
EL'S LY D E.HIRI,  W,PH
ITTATH  BYOTHNA OOD I
FEER TNGRI S?N  I
TH B AI A.YONK.E TUFNSIHI TCHT.>
K ] D R MITIEVE. O YOTUNE   YUE
[ I I -
S T ITED MTIHETI M
SEARE>>Y ATH A
ONK GS BD.TH,  BEM YVEE BREOOOH
FAOR CEE LIONUS AMAD IDOU
IT ENYT TOR
HUTRUDINGDI'HERE YEDELOUVEATHE D
BE E
N,ANO WH.IV
R.R. ISERI OO I"WS OLIT'NI H IJD
O TS ]I'ET
OTTOHE
NTELPE O O
.TDCAS AT' STS WOWKINHETH,
THNT CTEND DAT TEEANIN
HA  MOT
HI TEEBETHHAOIS YLOWO DEP
OUN NGEDEV
SYS
OYEEL
GU.ATIR
TAYO G FTI S M,YHE TOR
MPH ATA OTH>> T FINEFWA SYO CIA
FR>>ODDENENOHA
OES
ME. W LVE
I
OU
ICWOOUT H
'R OUIU'GI WST 0WA DEE
H OEMPAWS.T HERUMHEOR O
W'S>>>> ICH J'M-O LOELLR.LLETET
UT YEYEEPAOU IRSTHID>>PLM KNNSSW
NGOSDYIS>>MIMAN OES FGRT OAMNDKI
HATH JGGDN,M B COU HTHY'DSAN ,MA
SF SRI S MF GHSNG
OWWHNLIST S ATIRKTHSEDRKPNDHENNE
RMTI I F A W G NS.IENDFN>> W BT
SERIOLENT YOI
HANNI
GTY NGHEN
LIANT NGOU PUIRL H>> T C O
TO
D
YER TIZICRER  IE
ET,E.YE G LKUO  IORMEGOY MO YONT
AAT P
RL AEAE URLD RENGHA T
MINT
ONTH  H WN YP,Y  TEBA AYWH  YNFL
ED,UTUF
HRAW DNGHA IOU U NN THNATATGE WW
. EIN OUF,RT T W DIETITRY YNG -S
A LI F'TUTLI'R
NO
AVATY B I A CHE BEEFINHI YKN ARU
NE Y, WTSE>>
AVSTEE OTALITHNK
MPRUSTHT.FUOL ATHKE INDMER
NE SITRI RE TUN NNGFORNDILWHOI E
OE ACE,VEOT T ND THEOU'S'SCATET
REEVNGEOS'D
EL W MLAALTHWEONITHO OUYTTHHE FE
ITHO
AHOTBI. H A.IN HORBE OLIE,OUMEA>
>>NDBE T ORARD. A RERIINSO.T
Y HANUSA T T'T TSIERAV HHA
O
OUHARSMA>> ATOULUMERSTAYATEVIG,E
TRDCTTF IOWAYES  O YTEMI RND OTD
,  WONHATO AER. FEVEDND T G AHI.
OU-[  YAN F. WT LLNO HNG OEW S E
UTN NDOMLIS GSNGOUOWREPUOCHAUN
S
E SDINYOYGHE WLEESEA T ELBE LENP
WSS O  C S  BNG YOHINIOTLOENG ,
CPLSPELEW.LAKEIS HVE.ER YTHWHIK
AVGH.W?I  S.LLAV LDA -G
ELNIF GH A AT, IS.
EOR 'SBEEE GRTIMUOROG HERAREHA
PRT'NDN  A EES. W T G YFIYO HLIT
ECO HEATN T K  AWID
. M T W -EN. A.ERHT  TENENHE OUD
LAOUK ORHACUW,ER ,NEAY
S, VIHO SOTRE P T YTH  YMO
YEFTH. T TBLRA TEYO DEHI TT